like if we're out at a store or  something running an errand he'll tell  the workers you better watch out for her  because she steals  but do you understand how that might  make her feel  like a criminal exactly  i mean i used to steal oh yeah  okay you used to steal what did you i  was totally kidding around no this is a  breakthrough i stole skittles from  blockbuster i stole a stick of gum once  from the uh market  i stole a bracelet from express i stole  another bracelet from express hat  someone told me to return it i stole a  headband from urban outfitters once i  stole a hat  okay and this this list doesn't say  there's some validity  this is a crime spree that the hillside  strangler would envy